cette marraine de l'opération est-ce que
cet appel de confection de masques a été
entendu j'ai discuté hier quelqu'un du
chu qui m'a laissée en tant qu après
justement cet appel ils ont reçu au
moins deux sens a fait deux couturières
qui veulent participer donc à
l'opération bon d'accord je pense que
c'est déjà un bon début et je crois que
au fur et à mesure les gens le sauront
certainement se manifester aujourd'hui
un l'appel a été lancé le 2 nous sommes
le 4 où en est on aujourd'hui est ce
qu'on peut déjà faire un point sur le
nombre de masques confectionnés
alors pour le moment les couturières
sont réquisitionnés pour faire lécher
aux blues parce que comme les ingénieurs
comme les tous les tissus cancer du sein
et au blues
on est obligé de se débrouiller
fabriquait déjà parce qu'il ya une
grosse ya encore quelques masques donc
les masques concurrencer puisqu'ils sont
à la découpe sont pas les couturières
qui vont les découper mais s'est
découpée à l'extérieur et elles seront
fournis pour démarrer et justement la
fabrication de ces masques dès lundi
alors ces masques etc sur blues sont
adressés haye qui précisément alors les
sur blues sont évidemment adresses sont
adressés au personnel soignant qui est
qui et qui est directement là et les
masques en général c'est c'est pour le
personnel qui en soutien des soignants
et qui les côtoient c'est à dire des
secrétaires médicales
le personnel dédié à l'hygiène ceux qui
vont enlever tous les déchets compagnie
également les personnels qui travaillent
en laboratoire
parce que les masques chirurgicaux sont
essentiellement réservé aux gens qui
sont directement sur les placements à
travailler sur les passions alors vous
vous êtes marraine de l'opération en
quoi était ce important pour vous de
relayer cette mobilisation
on m'a appelé on m'a demandé aux radis
jeu simon a besoin de toi j'ai bondi à
l'avant j'entends parler de man ray ne
s'était encore utilisent effectivement
parce que je finis ma part et de la
faire mais en fait je sais juste une
participation je pense comme n'importe
quel artiste ou n'importe quelle
personne aurait accepté de faire alors
justement on parle de masques avec des
si lavables réutilisables fabriqués par
des attitudes et des artisans
il ya un protocole bien précis à
respecter ce protocole bien passé c'est
ce sont les matières qui sont utilisés
voilà donc c'est un dossier qui est
extrêmement médical et donc ses traités
par par des responsables justement à
cacher aux autres associations qui
s'associe à ça est ce que dans des
couturières des coûts du alliés peuvent
encore répondre à cet appel
bien sûr bien sûr parce que bon c'est
c'est eh l'ensop la faux pas de masque
déjà on a 24 mille masques pour des gens
qui sont bien répertorié parce qu'il
faut aussi pour les vigiles pour tous
tous ces gens là quoique son qui sont
aux abords des hôpitaux et même aux
abords du marché sera bien pour lui en
donne également des masques un jour et
le citoyen lui même je veux dire chaque
personne doit avoir un masque coûteux
pour pouvoir se protéger quand ils
sortent très bien merci beaucoup je suis
une baignoire d'avant versini dans nos
questions